можемо починати
тоді дозвольте мені прийде яким
порядком нерідко отримали без колеги
вас поінформують про
тому що сьогодні динаміки як
працювали з ким спілкувалися
інформації будемо це ж ваші питання
сьогодні у нас третій день проведення
підсумкової зустрічі не науки та освіти
російської федерації в Україні хочу
нагадати що відповідно до третьої
смачною угоду підписано 2010 року
2001 року не освіти та науки україни
вересні та обіцянкою стовбура російської
федерації і як і передбачалося ми і
домовлялися
вересні 2012 року відбулися не
освіти та науки Російської Федерації
на сьогодні працювала 14 секцій труб та
стоїть конференції та семінари загальне
кількість тайський прибув з Росії
робіт вуха і це більше 200 чоловік одні
ніби венеції в 214 інші разом 16 і
та й інша більше понад двісті
працювали наступні серце та присвячене
початкову освіту
середнім професійним чином мені
серце співробітництво столичного
освіти міста Москви та міста Києва
працювали також у
керівники регіональних органів
управління в
утворити що наукові сфери Росії
України
працювали секції застосовували у вигляді семінар
інноваційні високі технології
ми познайомилися з роботою сільською
позашкільної освіти ми ось була
цікава зустріч і серце день
освіта що при явці на кожній
секції відбулася не просто обмін авто
високий рівень довіри та
конструктивної співпраці які
зібрані
хто мав можливість бути присутнім на
великому пленарному засіданні
бачили
одухотворені якщо гарний настрій
наших колег кожен для себе масу
цікаво якщо говорити про сухі якісь
більш кут тирський ніж освітній
центр ну наприклад тільки одна секція
яка об'єднувала керівників та
працівників столичної освіти
вони підписали 11 договорів це при тому
що минулого року у них більше ста було
пролонговано
окрему програму постійно
чинну створили вчені називали
епізодичних наук України та російської
академії освіти
більше цього дійшли механізм виграні
мігрантами
обслуговувати та
займатися спільними науковими ким я думаю
що дуже добрий досвід передали друг
другові працівники дошкільної освіти
це російський досвід
дитячих садків та українські досвід створення
навчально-виховних комплексів
секції приправила великі я вже що по
50 60 чоловік у кожний деякі теж не
реєстрували з офіціантом списку крім
того ми сьогодні маємо з моїм вже світ
колегою міністром освіти та довго
Російської Федерації spadina вліво на
тривале конструктивно хочу
зустрічі з прем'єр-міністром України
вечір за дитячими найширше коло
співробітництва в освітній
гуманітарній сфері у наукові намітили
ряд підходів до
зміцненню і до ширшого
співпраці найголовніше гаррієт не
несло тому, щоб це співробітництво
лікарів якнайбільше наукових колектив
причому не тільки
букету is true that cater досягали їх
це насіння та мультиплікації що було
адже охоплено якомога більше людей
нагальні проблеми і тому можемо бути
взаємно корисним та цікавим один одному
не тільки пряними
якимись спільними проектами як
спільний продукт ми спільним пошуком
вирішення тих чи інших проблем приємно
також відзначити що ось сьогоднішня
учень був підписаний меморандум про
взаєморозуміння між міністерством
освіти та науки Російської Федерації
міністерство освіти науки молоді
стоїть а україни і
промінвест банком про подальші заходи щодо
розвитку поглиблення співробітництва в
галузі загальної середньої освіти
тут багато пунктів та великий досить
документ завдання, яке ми поставили
перед собою переміститися тісними це
допомогти
створити і зразком показали найбільшого
розвивати це рівня найвищого рівня
якості освіти російської зберігати
гімназію де легким та
на себе промінвест і створення не
зведеш значення ми зі свого боку
повинні будемо взяти участь у морі
кращих викладачів з більш навчальних
соди та розробити механізм як
навчаючись у цій гімназії діти зможуть
державі атестат про повне
середній освіті
україни та Росії стартує пелені два
океану вищих освіти дуже коротка
я закінчую 38 всього шанованого
колегами прийшли душі дякую
Володимирович уже дали мені мало що можна
додати
скринліст я
складу xpeke там із двох сторін ці дні
ці зустрічі
або каналу всі обговорення велич візерунок
вони були присвячені найактуальнішим у
підняв проблему справжні нашим
міністерством та цілому нашими системами
освіти науки
проблематиці дошкільної освіти до
проблем
фізики та
роботи наших міністерств та весь спектр
роботи
наших людей які сьогодні працюють у
наших системах освіти
дуже важливо, що тільки намагалися
проблемам і пропонувалися конкретне
рішення та
як приклад можу навести
ініціативу на пропозицію якість
моментів при захисті дисертації України
осі і відповідно
обліку при захисті дисертацій у Росії
публікації українських науковий журнал та
навпаки
ще ціла низка дуже цікавих ініціатив
які умовно будуть нами
робота на я підтримую будуть
реалізовані та
дадуть нові відносини
дуже важливо у нас спільні проблеми
спільними за легше вирішувати проблеми спільно
легше ми об'єднаємося досвідом ми обговорюємо
можливі рішення і зрештою не
точніше знаходимо
шляхи розвитку
успіх науки та освіти в наших країнах
я безумовно хотів би подякувати
українських
колег
зустріч днів за теплу атмосферу
yaki-da
адже додаток чоловіки гори гейство
питання
показати
все ж таки як
геннадій який все-таки вона
готує
права людини
які європейці не тільки на слова про
будівництві будеш готувати точно
журналістам які здатні вибачатися
і політиків, які відрізняються свої
слова назад були відповідати
найкращих українці
росії та
ніколи
ага дівчатками
запропонував створити комісію з аналізу
емоційно
підручник історія як україна втечемо і в
російських як боги створили крейсер
умовна тут ініціатива з боку
на добудову двох країн тоді тоді звичайно
повітрям і зараз у російські говорячи про
очних узбіччях якості при виведенні наших
підручників та навчальних посібників з історії та
ми безумовно будемо працювати над тим
щоб якість підвищувалася
отже і покращувався
освіченість та толерантності або
соціалізації нашийники тому що історія
це
добре історія важлива отримувати
правильні уроки саме підручнику історії
готелю історія повинні
правильно адекватно коректно
давати можливість вилучення таких
лохів
справді сьогодні побачили вже
його історія
посібники називається росія україна
унікальне
подія та
чи нам їжу
робити
дійсно говорив у великій
гордістю про те, що за два роки вдалося
реалізувати проект на якій деякі
країни trading по півтора-два 10 років я
пам'ятаю в 2010 році я вперше сказав по
необхідності підготовки
навчального посібника для вчителів історії
як дорослих грамотних людей із вищим
освітою скільки було навколо цього
інсинуації вже й перевертаємо
журналісти які вміють брехати наливні
бачаться час говорили про те що
підручник для дітей різна програма ще
раз повторювати її навчальний посібник
вчителів і ось вона народилася навіть сама
прискіпливий і нікого бажані бачите
тут не
патріот україни росія нато масі я
тільки назву основні 5 модулів вони
набагато глибше модуль перша культура
стародавньої русі
докладний ризиковий парту пандіон та вази
ні пандіон і зіграв і ряд
будемо заглиблюватися
другий модуль російське дворянство
українська ж авто у повсякденності
соціально-політичного життя
1517 тут усі відносини жінки
домашнім пристроям
соснові лісники так далі
повсякденної радянської людини в
другої половини не читав ще думаю що
дуже цікаво і
значення іона милявська аренін розвиток
українського та російського усунення
а щодо цього підручника буде
цікавий кожному самій про мене що
є обов'язково його можна читати
можна не читати для того для тих, кому
достатньо води ідеологічних концепцій
та з питання національних підручників
історії і у нас у Росії є великі
дуже проекти які б'ють регіони це
регіональної історії і ви бачите не це
міста севастополь це підручники я думаю
що теж буде цікаво якщо
професіонали різних країн дивитись
підручник історії підказують як вони
можуть зробити їх краще
толерантніше більше
етапі більш тактовно скажемо
інформативніше так далі так далі так
далі і думаю що всім виграли що ж
стосується зразкових до української
гімназії тоді у майстра з'явилася
американська явно англійська гімназія 13
тисяч та 10000 доларів навчання у я не
пам'ятаю жодного негативного відгуку в
нашій пресі тепер коли
комерційну плату за свої гроші
пропонується створити потужну
освітню базу ми починаємо шукати
то чого в цьому проекті зроду не і
недержавні сьогодні нам доповіли
що вони полірують зареєструйтесь там
неприбуткової організації неприбуткової
ford частина дітей із соціально
незахищених категорій будуть повністю
безкоштовно навчатися отримувати все
можливі зверху стандартні
додаткові преференції до освіти
2 перейти на дивні там коли це
річка що повнить не занять частина дітей
які іногородні інші будуть
отримувати можна тут же проживати
якщо буде там
складова платної освіти що не
виключає статуту різні гуртки та
секції танцювальні спортивні і так
далі що передбачається і потужна
спортивна база спортивний зал басейн
секцій безумовно до цієї частини буде
ватні про намір власників цього
приміщення дефект відкладаю гроші вони
за втомився через опікунські поради всі
зароблені кошти крім тих що
виділяють на утримання
інвестувати в розвиток навчальної бази
розвитку бібліотеки лабораторної бази
навчального закладу мені здається що
проект досить симпатичний
гуманітарної використовувати
ця мрія коли буде проект вже
закінчено вони зможуть швидко чітко
покласти газета свято йшлося про те, що
буде
обмін викладачів вищої школи
стимулюватися але це все-таки буде
сама
або буде якийсь координаційний центр
щоб молодий викладач моду
звернутися і люльки чи в Москві що
він стискає працює при університеті
з іншого боку якась заборона
я
сьогодні є досить активний обмін
подавач на боці студенти фронтами
російськими військами
та науковими організаціями це кілька
тисяч людей 20 безумовно ми про це
людині говорили, що вона зацікавить
потрібно
зробити так щоб
підписували угоду ви ну немає номера
наші студенти мали змогу отримувати
дипломи провідних університетів
російського талінського одночасно і
сьогодні нам ректора доповіли що перші
такі угоди підписані я думаю що
якщо ми побачимо що потрібно до 11
потрібно створити формаційну пораду
раніше комітету
кожному з інститутів завізувати цей
процес обов'язково це зробимо будь-яким
випадку ми звичайно зацікавлені у тому
щоб коопераційні зв'язки між нашими
провідними науковими та давайте по
організації міражів
я думаю що ми будемо цей потримай
безумовно нових абсолютно за бажанням
це навряд чи можливо у будь-якому випадку
ви знаєте що у нас 2 розвиватиму цю
програму навчання та стажування за
кордоном
розрахована на
державний бюджет тільки для статі
для нас немає там есперанто минулого року
це було ввести sims 1
відправляється близько трьох сумісність
ми обмежили справі спеціальності це
найбільш технологічні спеціальності
затребувані кишені
Альтернативна енергетика
біотехнології треба зберігати ділового
Векторні гуманітарні цілком поки вони
не тягни державних, але нас було
три етапи конкурсу публіку саму
університеті потім кури курс
потім регіональні курсові комісії
в міністерстві, якщо пройшло в цю, було не
дуже висока довіра
а ось ці 307 срібних
publishing якщо людина кімнатні
умови будуть оприлюднені
вільні знання закон країни куди ти
хочеш вирушити вже готові наукові
роботи цілий ряд
ось ті, хто пройшли вони безумовно вчитися
на конкурсній основі стажується за рахунок
держави зменшує якщо минуле
створювалося багато європейських
університети кілька американський
тепер приклад дисбалансу американські та
європейські це найкраще з терапія
пам'ятаю
республіки кореї китайський народ
різні відблиски про фінансові ємності
програми
ми змушені підкорятися умовам тих
місць які є партнер я такий
вже систему відбудовуватимемо і з
Російської Федерації тут нам простіше
тому що є дуже багато двосторонніх
договорів про нож як сказав міністр його
на порядку 50 осіб, а в минулому
тільки навчальному році були у відрядженнях
раз тонування викладали викладачів
та професорів України в російській частині
одна одиниця і навпаки російські
професорів та викладачів у пресі
тоді слов'янка з малаги росії питання
гімназія все чудово підмін це
чудове питання таке планується
них перспективу організація не тільки
стандартів ноги іспитів по принесла
нове для вас вудильник схоже і наприклад
якщо студент хоче вчитися українців
студентів і стукає оборонки небезпеки
і слизький студент станеться ви
наприклад, тихо
практично скрізь однаково тисячі
історій чи це когось є?
питання про те, скільки студентів
навчається
у корейців у Росії та Росія в Україні
після і більш давні спаду
політичного життя можу сказати почну
цикл
значить по студентам, який відзначається
ми збільшили у 2010 році бюджетні кріти
та бюджетні квоти як з української
сторони так і з російської у нас тепер
взаємна круто звичайно каррутерс він
людина а загальна кількість порядку семи
з половиною тисяч молодих громадян
україни додатково на контрактній
основі відзначається у російській федерації
і трохи більше 6 тисяч та близько 6000
виходить
росіян в Україні та разом з квотами
але більше 14 тисяч але має тенденцію
шматочок щодо вашого питання
пісня не змовлялися
але я думаю що у нормальних людей
вчених професіоналів історія та
література диму тому що абсолютно
переконаний, що історія історія абсолютно
точна наука математика коли у нас
пройшло і політичне керівництво країни
була занадто
поглиблено підлозі занурену історію то
з його концепцій однаково сміялися
американські ставки європе та польські
українські які не середини та
російські теж тому, що всі ці
концепції щодо фарби та
технічного характеру та тихими не
подій вони просто натрапляю на
абсолютно точно однакову для вчених
всіх країн документальну базу і коли
ми дивилися трагедія голодомору то це
знають усі починаючи від університету
едмонтона чи там головацького що найбільш
страшні втрати від голови зазнало
сільське населення саратівської області
42 відсотки недорахуватися це при тому
що казахів жителів казахстану
саме печі вийти порахувати при не можна
було не було паспарту поштових адрес
тому історія дуже точна наука що
стосується синхронізації еге і цінував ну
чесно кажучи поки ти там своїх і зір
складно говорити нам ідуть поки що його
удосконалювати розібратися та
безумовно безумовно
порахую для технічних спеціальностей
напевно потрібно
загальні підходи для того, щоб просто
піднімати рівень і в одній країні та
інший і робить підготовку наших
студентів майбутніх наших старшокласників
а сьогоднішній більш конкурентної
і для російської виграли танського
вітаміни та стрункості цю люди ще дуже
важливо
працює над тим, щоб
наші були системи обліку та розрахунку
іспиту між собою надію, що спід
математики та хімії
тут не стану сперечатися історія героя
всі предмети шкільні знання бородою
потрібні однаково оцінювався в Росії та в
україні
тому нам дуже важливо не ставити собою
мета широкій дефекації що на це
можливо скоро я зміг
певної специфіки зробити навіть
можливості ще одна іншу яким
чином розширилися можливості
доступу російських громадян для навчання
для отримання пішов українців
університетах хоча
російських вузах ось цієї мети думаю що
і перед собою ставитиму працювати над
тим, щоб давати можливості наших
громадян та шиї
зараз 5 0 це керівництво турист на
найближчі півроку ми хоч завдань
оскільки бути григорій з російською
сторони я з англійської кортні
майже півтора десятка ви зіграли а своєю
влада яка указу президента нашої
країни
росії відповідно включені
гуманітарний при комітет перед
мін-оборони
поставимо завдання відпрацює систему
розширити
освітні можливості наших що
стосується історії що модель
якщо. але в нашому модулі великого
зводити на 18 їх у нас вчать нехай 12
годинників залежно від того який профіль
напишемо про Росію велика сидить на війна
українського народу це частого та набору
освоєння підкорення сибіру схуднення чекаємо
ваші діти вчать кілька годин різних
а у нас це про навчальну програму один
урок освоєння цілини прохід березі ліс
накопичувально у нас у всесвітній історії
виглядає як кука або колумба це
ознайомлення а національні програми
іспанії та сполучених штатів про це
більше говорять але але точність від цього
не повинна змінюватися
газі на поїзд крокувала ваніно скажіть
будь ласка
які будуть і освіта науки у 13-му
році не будуть лити вирішили тому що ви
знаєш що є кіт нещодавно закінчився
прекрасний росії франції франції про
росії росії кишені та германії краси
два дні обмаль судячи з тих цих
прекрасним про що які нас ви не
чули і ми брали участь в роботі
стала по вашій школі що наш до 12 на
13 роки нові зусилля, а якщо серйозно то
звичайно на skype дуже гарного коли
проходив рік росії в Україні будуть
україни в Росії якщо не змінює полів
до полком 2002 це був
російське дорогу
Росії потім наступний рік Росії
рівень і була велика масштабна
проблема придумаєш ми можемо подумати
над оформленням та освітою
тринадцятому році якщо згоден важливими
ширини я б хоч і послуга ось ми знайшли
спільну мову і винесли їх ми несли за
рамки дідка за рамки столичної
міліції що це буде дуже важливо ну ще
я абсолютно переконаний що і минулорічні
цього року накопичення мультиплікації
прямих у сторонніх договорів вона одна
зупинка якості та подумати якщо
минулого року після довгої перерви 100
із зайвим середніх навчальних закладів Києва
та Москви
відновилися в італії про логінова
пролонгувати рим і
двосторонні договори про справи тонів
Москві близько тисячі шкіл і цей сюрприз
з критики і це кожна п'ята школа в
Москві більше ніж кожне десяте якщо
ні зовсім вже відверто можете будувати
у пресі я думаю що тільки
багато тому що далеко не всі 500
київських шкіл зразковий думаю що не
всі 1000 разів школи в Москві тому на
червоних та договірні відносини ті кому
є що розповісти чим поділитися
вколов методик цікавого проведення
об'єднання свої кабінети baume що там
проходить і клубу її дочки лікар у цьому
році додалася ще 11 нових якого я
п'ю тільки серце та столичне
освіта
що буде 13 м фіаско блюдо я думаю
потрібно двосторонню базу налагоджувати
розширювати освітні можливості
для наших громадян та їх наносити цих
днів за рамки тільки залишиться ніяких
контактами регіонами стати важлива
дуже 1 ставка у 1804 році by що
імператор Олександр II типу чого не гей
підписано два образи створення казанського
університету та homies ось сьогодні вони
зробили закінчили раніше працювали
кілька місяців займалися зробили
програму співробітництва
наукову обміном букрін
може бути наступного року казанський
харківський університет може ви до шару
цікавий формат мені освіта більше
перев'язані двом великим історично
цікавим крем
скажіть, будь ласка, не тільки покликання
науки пройшли ажурні говорити з науковцями
цікавіше за проект варто чекати
журналісти часто якщо дефіцит
я б хотів сказати що сама навчальна
посібник для вчителів історії поки що
навчання тому
вчені з
оцінками повноправного учасника ці
книги зустрічі ми
обговорили цілий ряд навколо
існували до сліз
наук та
трагічних 0 україна та іншими
освіти російської ми
шум справі проблема не
торкаюся твоїх великих наукових установок
нас є кілька проектів створення
їх встановлення світового класу та таких
проектів у рамках широкої міжнародної
кооперації та безумовно україна тут
для нас
це історичний так не це так тому
що українські фізики а сьогодні
справді
знімаємо провідних втому та акцентування та
тоді тому ми
розраховуємо на те, що через кількість
галузі науки
буде яндекс фіксованим результатом
зустрічі на 3
не повторюй стільки тобольської крики де
брали участь переговори вогнем я замість
без обіду мене не думі і там є
спільні треки будуть цікаві ділянки
волокнами чи не накажете
звичайно це не харківський фізтех до речі
і той і інший ще
ось цей мега проекті знаменитому
колайдері там ще росії є одним
зі спонсорів
творців несе фінансове навантаження до
створення полів світу і приваблює наших
навчальних стрільб з корейської та місце та
близькі скрін з краєвидами
політехніки тисяч інших конкретиків якщо
а сьогоднішній круглий стіл
насіння за інноваційною сумою тихим я
втечі наук та круглий стіл по нубику
технологіям любить технології
розшифровує вона набір інформаційних
і пильні та технологій ліво вбий його
патона титану пишу на папірці сам був
піонером цього є центром
курчатова це блискучий молодий
колектив дуже цікавий директор
приходь статті з україни з миколаївської
області міста Першотравневий ось брав участь
там велика група і стукають російської
інституту з нашої гостроти кібернетики
тому там більш ніж конкретніше
напрацювання просто inформат не дозволяв
все це врахувати
дякую ми ще
питання
президента
не
вийшло ось що заважає і такий як
допомагають виконання цього завдання і ось
такі ось не освіта ринку
безумовно допомагають, бо сьогодні
сьогодні
скажу на дівчат маючи
проектів, які можуть безумовно
сприяти прийняттю рейтингу
рейтингу наших великих навчальних закладів
допомагаючи що заважає заважати те, що ніхто
є наших університетів до недавнього
часу
не купував у лапках усередині енергії
гасити потрапити бачимо можна пройти
певний був зробити величезний
обміркував і зміну у нас вийшло
якусь про дику розповімо чим спокою
проклинає проклинає перед постив
молився церкві виходив христинка і за 90
років життя жодного разу не виявив навіть батарей
і коли починає вчетверте ніж ти
хоч Всевишнього відкрилися небеса
з'явився lexa [ __ ] і бігаєш і всемогутній
але через 90 видів я один шанс у житті
прикупив лотерею так ось це фінське
національне місце цими дуже я
зайнявся щільно придбанням лотерейного
квитка виявилося щось величезне того
що цей лотерейний квиток потрібно тайською
постояти
метафоричним різні великі черги і
загалом вдалося увійти в 500, а що
заважає увійти успішно негативу sky
опозиції машин пресах нашої обмовився
назвав цей рейтинг 2 тижні сміялися
тому ніхто тайський з
залишаться загалом теж не надрукувати
спростування хоча києві блищить на
сьогоднішній зробив ривок та обстеження
з половиною більш ніж густого та тисяч
університету поповнимо написано 30 позицію
у лондонському ринку це медичний факт
я про це говорив не міг назвати
точний рядок з оптичної причини
порт тобто рада рейтингу поставила то
кінця дня не ризикувати вересня
інформаційні банки для того, щоб
вперше на першому на своєму сайті але
сьогодні це вже відбулася дякую